[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
dans points de vue autour de deux
invités qui vont débattre de l'actualité
la plus immédiate
bonsoir ira chez le binât ce vous êtes
journaliste vous collaborez notamment à
l'express et à marianne votre dernier
enquêter sur la sphère adama traoré dans
marianne justement bonsoir richard ben
oui bonsoir il vous est maire-adjoint
premier adjoint même socialiste à la
maire du 12e et vous êtes également co
directeur de l'observatoire sport et
sociétés de la fondation jean jaurès
nous commençons si vous le voulez bien
par parler de cette actualité tragique
de l'essonne ou en moins de 24 heures
deux adolescents sont morts à la suite
d'affrontements entre bandes
ces affrontements augmente le nombre de
violences entre bandes de mineurs a
s'est accru de 24 % l'année dernière
malgré le confinement et le couvre-feu
qui aurait dû théoriquement limité ce
genre de violences que faut-il faire il
ya sûrement pas de solution miracle je
vous propose de nous focaliser ce soir
sur la responsabilité des parents
écoutez ce qu'en disait gérald darmanin
le ministre de l'intérieur était hier
soir sur les lieux du drame
la société n'est pas responsable de tout
et que les policiers les gendarmes les
maires ne peuvent pas faire à la place
des parents une autorité qui consiste à
ne pas sortir seul le soir quand on est
un jeune adolescent d'aller suivre des
études ou une formation professionnelle
de ne pas avoir ce qui était le cas des
béquilles des armes blanches des barres
de fer
je pense que on conviendra tous ensemble
que ce n'est pas l'équipement naturel
d'un enfant de 13 ans de 14 ans dans la
rue est rappelé que les parents ont un
devoir d'autorité alors il en train de
voir c'est même une responsabilité
pénale dans certains cas c'est l'article
227-17 du code pénal qui a dit que s'il
est le père ou la mère se soustrait à
ses obligations légales au point de
compromettre la moralité la sécurité la
santé ou l'éducation de son enfant
mineur
et bien ce parent peut être puni jusqu'à
deux ans d'emprisonnement et 30 mille
euros damende je voudrais vous livrer ce
témoignage est celui d'un des meilleurs
spécialistes
la violence des enfants il s'appelle
maurice berger il est pédopsychiatre
il enseigne à l'école nationale de la
magistrature et il travaille dans ce
qu'on appelait les centres éducatifs
renforcés c'est à dire des lieux fermé
pour mineurs délinquants et lui dit tout
se passe comme si les parents étaient
intouchables
quels que soient leur laxisme éducatif
où les négligences violence
exposition en violence conjugale
auxquels ils soumettent leurs enfants
dans toute ma carrière je n'ai jamais
obtenu une seule fois que cet article
donc le celui que je viens de vous citer
soit utilisé par un magistrat richard
houis quelle est selon vous la
responsabilité des parents dans cette
violence des mineurs qui augmente de
façon constante
je pense qu'il faut y mettre la
poussière sous le tapis ni enflammé une
situation je m'explique
dire comme certains que les parents
n'ont aucune responsabilité me paraît
pour le coup et responsable tout mettre
sur le dos des parents me paraît tout
aussi responsables
quand dans certaines familles pour
certains parents la situation est déjà
très difficile
et eux mêmes sont parfois débordé par la
manière dont se comportent leurs propres
enfants
donc il faut je pense avoir une
situation à la fois une lecture qui est
sérieuse qui est lucide mais qu'il
enflamme pas les situations je le dis
très clairement dans toutes les
situations que moi j'ai à connaître en
tant que adjoint dans le 12e
arrondissement parfois effectivement on
a des parents qui n'ont pas forcément ou
non pas toujours dans l'éducation les la
rigueur qu'on pourrait attendre d'eux il
y en a d'autres qui le disent très
clairement ils sont dépassés débordé et
ils se sentent parfois impuissants à
pouvoir reprendre le contrôle sur
l'éducation de leurs enfants eux mêmes
nous disent être en difficulté et c'est
aussi cela que j'ai envie qu'on entende
qui est qu'est ce que l'on met en place
pour aider les parents à reprendre leurs
responsabilités à reprendre autorité sur
l'éducation de leurs enfants quand elle
n'est plus là et souvent on le sait
beaucoup trop tardivement contient même
plus de liens parfois entre les parents
et les enfants eux-mêmes donc on a un
vrai sujet qui interroge à la fois les
parents sur ce qu'on met en place à côté
et puis voilà
cibler la responsabilité des parents où
il n'y a pas que ça il ya aussi tout ce
qu'on peut mettre en place à la fois à
l'école avec les clubs de prévention
mais on y reviendra et toutes les
actions à côté pour renforcer à la fois
la place des parents mais aussi la place
de tous les acteurs qui sont des qu'aux
éducateurs à un moment donné et qui
doivent aussi prendre leur part dans
cette danse est à faire vous parlez de
votre expérience d'élu est ce que dans
le 12e arrondissement de paris vous
connaissez ce phénomène de violence de
mineur alors sur paris par rapport à ce
que vous avez évoquées qui est juste un
dans votre introduction l'année 2020 a
plutôt été une année où la délinquance
des mineurs a diminué on sent que
c'était énormément liée à une circo
circonstances très exceptionnelles d'une
année pas comme les autres en revanche
l'année précédente
la voilà la délinquance des mineurs elle
était présente à elle était même en
hausse
on y distingue plusieurs choses il y a à
la fois de la délinquance qu'on peut
appeler celle qui est liée au phénomène
de rixes et ça c'est quelque chose qui
est présent dans le 12e arrondissement
on a même une bande qui est connu pour
exporter ailleurs dans paris
ces phénomènes de délinquance on à la
délinquance qui peut être liée à tout ce
qui est le trafic de drogue ça existe
aussi dans le xiième et dans d'autres
arrondissements d'ailleurs à paris ce
n'est pas propre à cet arrondissement
on a des phénomènes de rixes par band ça
c'est quelque chose que l'on connaît
dans le xiième et qui a d'ailleurs fait
l'objet récemment à la fin janvier d'une
violente opposition entre deux bandes
rivales avec d'ailleurs derrière une
sanction immédiate pour une des
personnes à l'origine de cet
affrontement qui a été placée dans un
des centres éducatifs fermés dont vous
parlez c'est une sanction qui est
immédiate et qu est plutôt assez rare
quand elle est appliquée aussi
rapidement ça voulait donc dire qu'il y
avait des éléments qui ont montré qu'il
fallait être très sérieux et puis on a
il faut le dire aussi une explosion de
la délinquance des mineurs liés aux
mineurs non accompagnés qui représentent
une grande partie près de 50 % qui sont
des leaders l'étranger abolissons seul
mais qui ne sont pas expulsables même
cet instant situation est exactement et
pour lequel la france de la protection
et on est régulièrement interpellé par
une série d'associations qui s'en occupe
en disant que l'état ne fait pas
forcément ce qu'il faut mais en tant la
réalité si on parle de délinquance
ils sont aussi présents donc on a un peu
cette multi facettes et puis on a la
délinquance qui n'en est pas en tant que
une mais qui est ressenti par les
habitants comme pouvant être une et je
parle de toutes les délinquances sonore
c'est quand on bat chez vous avez des
jeunes qui se réunissent qui parle fort
on est au moment du confinement
tout ça prend des proportions ce n'est
pas en tant que tel délinquant
structurelles mais par contre elle pose
un souci aux habitants elles les
empêchent parfois même de vie exactement
et c'est des formes d'incivilités qui
sont vues d'une manière très différente
entre ceux qui sont à l'origine et puis
ceux qui la vivent
mais qui en subissent parfois les les
désagréments d'une manière très très
personnel et très violente et pour
lequel là on a encore d'autres donc à
chaque fois il faudra il faut car entre
la police la justice parce qu'il faut
aussi que l'on parle de ce sujet il faut
que sur la présence aussi d'une police
de proximité on puisse avoir des
réponses adaptées à ces différents
niveaux de délinquance qui existe
rachel bennette votre point de vue je
sais quoi rendre qu'on puisse qu'on
marche un peu sur des oeufs quand on
traite ce sujet que ce soit difficile
qu'on soit un peu gêné aux entournures
quand il s'agit justement d'aborder la
question de la responsabilité des
parents que ça n'explique pas tout
certes mais c'est quand même un sujet
qu'on a du mal à aborder dans le débat
public depuis longtemps ça ne date pas
d'aujourd'hui
en réalité les propos de monsieur
darmanin font écho à ceux de monsieur
chevènement 99
lorsqu'ils décident de se saisir de
cette question là qui se met à dos
d'ailleurs toute une partie du peps à ce
moment-là qu'il parle de sauvageons il
parle de sauvages ans il parle également
de l'idée de suspendre les allocations
les prestations familiales voire même
peut-être d'écarter en temps l'enfant de
son contexte de vie et ça ça va être
extrêmement mal reçue par par le ps donc
c'est une espèce de marronniers
politique que personne ne veut
réellement traité et dont en réalité
personne ne veut vraiment voir de quoi
il s'agit j'entends la queue on parle
des difficultés parental elle existe est
un fait donc le parent peut être
démissionnaire entre guillemets pour de
bonnes raisons mais aussi de mauvaises
raisons et ses parents là sont aussi de
plus en plus nombreux c'est à dire des
parents qui vont considérer que c'était
la collectivité de prendre en charge
leurs enfants en enseignants disent et
ils déposent leurs enfants et le balance
comme on dépose un sac de linge sale
devant la devant l'école et il ya
énormément de professeurs d'éducateurs
qui alerte et là dessus qu'ils
désespèrent de la déresponsabilisation
des parents qui convoque une fois deux
fois trois fois
les parents ne viennent jamais ne se
déplace jamais et il faut le dire c'est
pas forcément parce qu'on va pas
essentialiser la pauvreté c'est pas
forcément dans des familles dans des
familles qui vivent dans une misère des
moins de là c'est parfois au sein même
de famille issue de la classe moyenne
donc cccd sujet et qu'il faut mettre à
l'ordre du jour c'est des outils sur
lesquels il faut se pencher alors certes
on a déjà un arsenal législatif
juridique là dessus apparemment c'est
pas suffisant
il ya des parents qui n'ont pas envie 1
de se charger qui n'ont pas d'intérêt en
fait un qui ne portent pas d'intérêt à
leur enfant pour deux motifs pour des
motifs assez assez distincts et ça c'est
une question qui va falloir se poser
parce qu'en fait elle s'impose à nous
elle s'impose à nous on appelle ça des
faits divers ce ne sont pas des faits
divers sont des faits sociaux
alors nos internautes considèrent très
majoritairement que les parents sont
responsables des délits commis par leurs
enfants vous pose la question sur
twitter et vous répondez oui à 77%
voici quelques réactions celle de vlc
youtube on a rendu les gens beaucoup
trop puis responsable au profit de nos
libertés si des personnes décident
d'avoir un enfant elles sont
responsables
une suppression des allocations
familiales seraient justifiées nicole
0,6 sur lefigaro.fr qui déplore que les
enfants à problèmes ne soit plus mis en
pension en maison de redressement comme
on les appelait en tout cas il y avait
une sanction alors que ricco sur
lefigaro.fr considère que s'en excuser
il faut voir que les jeunes donc plus de
sport que l'école est à mi temps à cause
de la crise sanitaire et marie flory sur
youtube c'est notre devoir de les aider
à grandir pour qu'ils prennent leurs
responsabilités à leur tour je crois à
la valeur de l'exemple
richard briguait ces jeunes dont vous
parlez on les connaît ils sont
identifiés dans votre arrondissement est
ce que ce sont toujours les mêmes qui
reviennent ne font pas toujours
identifiés et d'ailleurs
jeunesse passe aussi ce qui est vrai a
intenté à cinq ans plus tard c'est pas
les mêmes c'est pas les mêmes personnes
c'est pas les mêmes bandes c'est pas
exactement les mêmes structuration dans
les bandes c'est pas les mêmes profils
donc attention les choses bougent
par contre il ya des réalités qui sont
que certains quartiers qui
historiquement sont des quartiers dits
de bande c'est à dire là où on retrouve
des bandes de jeunes
historiquement si on prend une partie
assez longue dans le temps sur le 12e on
retrouve paradoxalement quasiment les
mêmes quartiers on rappelle que le
deuxième glissement s'est complètement à
l'est de la capitale
il ya même une le bois de vincennes qui
bien que les remparts dans paris fait
partie de l'âme alors on met quand même
les faits qui se passe dans le bois de
vincennes
on les met un peu de côté pourquoi non
pas pour ne pas les prendre en compte
mais parce que c'est une situation très
particulière et une population qu'on ne
retrouve pas du tout dans
l'arrondissement
les personnes qui vivent au delà de ceux
qui ont une adresse légale je désire
mais toutes les personnes qui sont là
pour des raisons souvent de misère pour
des raisons d' exclusion on a beaucoup
de sdf on travaille beaucoup avec des
maraudes cr en gros des services de la
préfecture du samusocial d'associations
qui viennent et des oeufs et des agents
de la ville
on a vraiment une population qui est
très particulière et qui ne peut pas
statistiquement être assimilé à ce qui
se passe à on intra muros mais en intra
muros
on a des quartiers qui depuis des années
depuis 40 ans sont des quartiers où sont
présents des des phénomènes de jeunes et
de bandes et pourtant ils grandissent
alors il transmettre à leurs enfants
comment je le sais c'est pas exactement
ça mais ça veut dire que c'est pour ça
en fait il y à la fois quels sont les
types de populations qui habitent dans
ces quartiers on a peut-être un sujet
sur la mixité sociale est ce qu'on a pas
là par moment un empilement de mêmes
familles qui rencontrent les mêmes
difficultés qu'elles soient sociales
éducatives de
lien en parentalité avec leurs enfants
avec bref on a peut-être ce sujet de
quartier qui ont besoin d'avoir un autre
type de population plus mix plus
mélanger ça c'est un premier pas on a
deux ennemis que j'étais aussi je mets
les pieds dans le plat mais être né
coupat est ce que ce sont beaucoup des
gens qui viennent de l'immigration
ethnique
si je fais une analyse historique pas
nécessairement je prends un exemple
quand j'étais gamin mes parents me
disaient de ne pas aller dans certains
quartiers parce que dans ces quartiers
d'une 12e il y avait des bandes et il y
avait des phénomènes de délinquance je
remarque si je met à plat aujourd'hui
les phénomènes de la délinquance tête
qu'ils sont observés avec le commissaire
avec la mer avec l'adjoint en charge de
la sécurité à paris où elle dans le 12e
arrondissement
je remarque que ce sont les mêmes
quartiers qui sont ciblés est ce que
c'est les mêmes populations non est-ce
que c'est uniquement à l'époque où j'en
parle quand j'étais gamin c'était pas du
tout les mêmes et pourtant cédé même
endroit les mêmes territoires les mêmes
objets qui sont qui sont constatés donc
je me dis qu'il ya cette permanence la
de lieux davantage que la permanence des
personnes elles-mêmes qui effectivement
changé c'est pas les mêmes
cinq ans plus tard où 10 ans plus tard
et finalement aussi peut-être
heureusement pour certains il ya aussi
un passage pour d'autres par contre y en
a pas il ya une structuration dans la
délinquance qui s'installe aussi dans le
temps mais tout ça nous oblige vous
comprenez bien avoir des réponses qui
sont aussi adaptés moi je m'interroge
aujourd'hui pour savoir pourquoi x
années après là où mes parents ne me
disait de ne pas aller c'est aujourd'hui
encore dans cet endroit que se trouve
une des bandes qui est reconnu pour être
en capacité de mettre des rixes de
mettre des les plans de bataille en
place contre d'autres banques
une vente certaines personnes à peu près
dans votre arrondissement alors c'est un
peu un problème a détaillé parce qu'on
le sait souvent quand il ya les points
de fixation et donc ça peut être une
trentaine de personnes mais est-ce qu'on
connaisse et 30 personnes
elles peuvent être 50 à un moment donné
puis de nouveau 10 peut-être que le
noyau c'est une dizaine qui grossit mais
voilà on les a au moment mon à
l'interpellation on à la police qui est
en capacité de regarder ce qui se fait
ou on allait les les informations donc
encore une fois on est plutôt sur des
bandes d'une trentaine mais qui peuvent
grossir jusqu'à 50 quand il ya un
affrontement données pour des guerres
dit
territoriales il faudrait voir ce qu'on
met encore derrière mais qui sont plus
des prétextes ou derrière il ya en plus
des rivalités de famille des rivalités
de fait des anciens fait qu'ils
reviennent x années après enfin des
communautés les unes contre les autres
ça dans le 12e arrondissement je ne peux
pas évoquer deux communautés contre
communauté c'est parce qu' aujourd'hui
structures là la délinquance dans cet
arrondissement ce qui ne veut pas dire
que ça n'existe pas mais dans mon
arrondissement je ne peux pas évoquer ce
phénomène la rachel un dernier mot on
d'accord écouté longuement richard oui
mais c'était intéressant d'avoir ce
témoignage mais non de d'élu de terrain
non mais ça nous permet aussi de mettre
à l'agenda des questions qui qui peuvent
être pertinentes c'est à dire la
question de la suspension pas des
allocations familiales on l'a vu
certains maires travaille dans ce sens
là la question des associations des
allocations municipales pour les mères
c'est pas des allocations nationales
c'est bien des allocations municipales
qu'ils ont décidé qui peut comprendre sa
vocation mais aussi des aides par
exemple de la mairie pour aller en cours
en vacances c'est donc idéal familial
s'est passé l'exercice et les adhérents
mais là aujourd'hui zone à laval en soi
ou à fois ci c'est sur les allocations
municipales qui sont donc il ya cette
question là la question aussi de de
l'éloignement de l'enfant de sa famille
et puis effet des moyens donnés à la
justice parce que ce qu'on le sait il ya
énormément de choses à travers l'
ordonnance de 45 elle est à peu près
complète mais la question c'est celle de
son application
je crois par exemple ce qu'on appelle le
trouble de jouissance c'est à dire des
jeunes parce qu'il faut se poser la
question là quand ça se fait que des
jeunes de 12 13 ans soit dans la rue et
d'îles parfois alors on pourtant en a
les moyens
on pourrait poursuivre les parents
justement pour trop de vices de
jouissance on promène parfois les
expulser des hlm dont il bénéficie ça a
déjà été fait mais c'est trop peu fait
donc il ya un sentiment de l'impunité
qui est qui et qui est totale chez les
parents avec là aussi qu'il faut
accentuer des choses qui sont le travail
avec tous les clubs de prévention il
faut que ça redevienne une vraie
politique pas quelque chose qui est
juste instrumentalisée au dernier moment
mais comment la prévention devient une
vraie politique avec des moyens la
police de proximité
moi je souhaite que dans les réflexions
qu'il ya sur la police municipale à
paris on s'occupe aussi de la présence
des jeunes mineurs dans la rue dans
l'espace public à un moment donné ça
sera de la responsabilité tout le lien
avec les associations et avec l'école il
faut pas que ce soit sur ce il faut pas
prévention première c'est celle des
parents mais qu'on peut pas non plus
tout attendre ni mais c'est penser que
ce n'est pas en supprimant les
allocations que nécessairement ya aucune
statistique qui montre aujourd'hui que
si vous supprimez les allocations
brutalement vous responsabiliser les
parents d'un point de vue moral je te
l'entendre sa patrie si je peux pas
défendre bien sûr on l'appliquera je
peux comprendre qu'il faut ça a été fait
c'était à l'époque où ça avait été
envisagée on avait vu que ça avait peu
de monde et peu d'incidences donc en
gros que ce n'était pas forcément la
matière et aujourd'hui on a pas d'étude
qui à l'époque l'idée était en
particulier de sanctionner l'absentéisme
scolaire par des départs la diminution
des allocations familiales en termes de
caractère de sanction pardon je laisse
le dernier mois pragma sur youtube qui
nous dit il ya beaucoup de parents qui
sont sincères et impuissant face à leurs
enfants qui deviennent indépendants très
tôt les causes sont multiples reparlera
sûrement de ce sujet je n'espère pas
trop vite si c'est pour assister à des
catastrophes à des drames plutôt comme
celui que nous venons de vivre on parle
maintenant d'un sujet un peu moins
dramatique mais tout stone actualité le
rsa pour les jeunes vous allez
qu'aujourd'hui fait d'avoir 25 ans pour
être éligible comme on dit au revenu
minimum à moins d'avoir travaillé un
minimum de deux ans entre 18 et 25 ans
alors faut-il compte tenu des
difficultés de l'époque et notamment de
l'incapacité des étudiants à faire des
petits boulots comme on dit pour
financer leurs études vu la condition
sanitaire faut-il
élargir aux étudiants le rsa voici deux
points de vue pour vous permettre de
vous faire le vôtre
d'abord celui de louis gallois c'est un
grand patron qu'on dit patron social car
c'est sa sensibilité il a été à la tête
d'airbus et de la sncf
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'il a
changé d'avis sur ce sujet il l'a dit il
ya deux jours à nos confrères d'europe 1
il ya quelques quelques années j'étais
assez réticent à l'idée d'accorder le
rsa aux jeunes parce que je me disais
que c'était pas une manière de rentrer
dans la vie pour un jeune que de
commencer à recevoir des êtres et moi
j'ai changé d'avis j'ai changé d'avis
parce que la situation des jeunes s'est
dégradée je pense qu'il faut leur donner
les ressources qui leur permettent de
s'engager dans une véritable recherche
d'activités et pour cela je pense que le
rsa c'est le minimum qu'on puisse leur
accorder voilà et comme en réponse le
lendemain toujours sur europe 1 la
ministre du travail et les abeilles
borne à expliquer pourquoi le
gouvernement était lui défavorable à
cette mesure qui fait y aider
financièrement les jeunes qui ne s'en
sortent pas évidemment c'est voilà il
n'y a pas de doute là-dessus et c'est
bien ce qu'on fait si tu es resté assez
loin de 25,1 nombre de groupes
politiques volent le rsa pour les jeunes
moi je dis qu'on doit plus que ça aux
jeunes on leur doit d'abord un
accompagnement vers l'emploi
c'est ce qu'ont fait par exemple avec la
garantie je sais répondre à la situation
des jeunes là dans l'immédiat avec une
aide financière mais c'est surtout d
accompagner vers un emploi du rhin voilà
la garantie jeunes c'est un dispositif
mis en place par le gouvernement à
l'occasion de la crise de lakovic 19
pour les jeunes entre 16 et 25 ans dans
des situations de grande précarité
je vous donne d'abord le point de vue de
nos internautes tels que on a pu
l'enregistrer sur twitter on vous a posé
la question êtes vous favorable à un rsa
pour les 16 25 ans et c'est non à 64%
donc il ya quand même un gros tiers de
nos internautes qui y est favorable
cette réaction
de jean-marc tranchant sur youtube payer
les jeunes à ne rien faire est ce
vraiment le message à envoyer pour
l'interrogation est
cette réaction de giovanni 28 toujours
sur youtube où vous pouvez nous suivre
en direct pour un mineur ça me semble
pas adéquat sauf s'il ne vit plus avec
ses parents mais il ya des jeunes en
pleine précarité qui le mériterait donc
la vie et la vie et partagés 10 25 ans
ce sont les majeures absolument rachel
bennette votre votre point de vue vous
êtes sans doute la plus mais sûrement
même la plus jeune d'entre eux y croient
un riche en dépenses et donc voilà
qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'est ce que vous
en pensez
bien au contraire comment vous dire
oui je suis pour ce il s'agit d'une aide
ponctuelle dans une situation de
difficulté bien sûr je suis pour et
c'est parfois triste de voir que
certaines personnes ne correspondent pas
ne couche pas toutes les cases alors
qu'elles sont dans une situation
extrêmement précaire
maintenant ce qui me dérange un petit
peu sur ce sujet là c'est que c'est
c'est aussi un pansement sur une jambe
de bois je m'explique je veux bien avec
la mieux est l'ami du travail nous
explique qu'au contraire il faut aller
plus loin et c il s'agit de le faire
aussi avec ce type d aide
on se fait l'économie d'un débat plus
profond et de réformes et de grands
chantiers qui s'imposent à notre société
et qu'on refuse depuis trop de temps
j'entends par là la question de de la
formation c'est à dire du nombre de
bacheliers complètement excessif des
universités qui sont sûrement des
déformations technologique dans
l'artisanat etc qui ne sont pas du tout
investi même mal perçue en france
contrairement à d'autres pays comme
comme l'allemagne
donc on crée en fait le concret nous
mêmes les situe elle cette situation là
et ses fragilités là et ensuite on
explique à ben on va venir avec un rsa
mais c'est aussi la question de la
formation continue c'est aussi en fait
tous ces grands chantiers de la qui
doivent être ouverts depuis un certain
nombre d'années ne le sont pas et on en
vient à ça on en vient à devoir donner
de l'argent à des personnes qui sont
dans une situation extrêmement précaire
alors on attend t on à mon attente et là
par exemple avec les alternances à celle
de la nouvelle mode qui très souvent
dans les entreprises sont là en fait
c'est du travail dissimulé
c'est un petit peu comme les stagiaires
c'est autant d'emplois qui devraient en
fait être pourvu et donner à des jeunes
sortant de l'université où des écoles et
on ne le fait pas donc on se tourne et
les entreprises ont beaucoup d'intérêts
avoir recours aux alternants à avoir
recours aux stagiaires il n'y a pas de
contrôles en plus quasiment pas dans ce
type d'entreprises
donc tous ces sujets là qu'on devrait
aborder d'un pur un certain nombre
d'années sont complètement ont mis sous
le tapis et parce qu on est face à des
situations extrêmement difficiles
on en vient à proposer un rsa pour les
jeunes alors je vais donner la parole à
richard il faudrait juste ajouté je vous
trouve sévère sur l'alternance parce que
c'est pas un moyen pour les jeunes qui
sont en formation d'avoir à la fois une
qualification à l'entreprise est aussi
une rémunération puisque donc c'est
peut-être un juste milieu où est donc
vous avez raison de me reprendre dans
certains milieux ces mêmes c'est même
nécessaire
il ya des milieux où il faut absolument
compléter le paysagiste ça sert à rien
de faire deux ans à l'école dans les
livres si vous n'avez pas un minimum de
terrain mais il ya aussi beaucoup
d'entreprises et on le voit depuis
environ un an
alors parfois sous prétexte avec la
libye ducobu qui fonctionne ou qui font
fonctionner leurs services avec des
alternants et ça c'est pas normal comme
on ne fait pas fonctionner un service
avec des stagiaires est en fait ces
stagiaires par exemple parce que c'est
quelque chose qu'on connaît bien ça on a
plus de recul là dessus sont là en fait
c'est quasiment du travail dissimulé
très souvent d'ailleurs il se remplacent
les uns et les autres et ses qualités
dans le temps et ils sont là exactement
mais pour un besoin qui est permanent en
réalité et tout ça c'est autant de
autant d'emplois chez les jeunes qui ne
sont pas pourvus et chats bruit vous
êtes pour ou contre un rsa pour les
moins de 25 ans je suis pour rsa pour
les moins de 25 ans mais ça ne vous
surprendra pas guillaume roquette la
proposition a été portée par le député
socialiste hervé saulignac et boris
vallot liberté de pensée vous n'êtes pas
forcément d'accord avec le vos camarades
mais mais mais mais absolument mais
laissez moi aussi être d'accord prévoit
quelques pas ce que je voulais c'est
venu pour le président toujours d'accord
mais il faut aussi que je sois connu
pour être parfois d'accord avec ceux qui
portent pourquoi parce que la situation
de la jeunesse est particulièrement
difficile aujourd'hui
moi je ne suis pas opposé à ce qu'on
dise mettons en place le rsa pour une
durée limitée et wallon ce qui se passe
regardons si ça fonctionne et si c'est
intéressant ou pas ça ne concerne pas
d'ailleurs que les jeunes qui sont
étudiants que les jeunes qui sont poste
bâches et c'est tout jeune c'est un
dispositif universel ça ne concerne pas
que les étudiants on est aujourd'hui
focalisée sur les effusions parce
qu'effectivement ils vivent
difficilement très difficilement pour
certains la période et on voit
régulièrement des files d'attentes
s'allongent et avec des jeunes qui vont
aller chercher des repas parce qu'ils en
ont besoin mais ça concerne aussi tous
ceux qui ne sont pas étudiants et qui
vivent aujourd'hui les mêmes difficultés
les difficultés aujourd'hui qui sont
celles simplement de vivre pour des gens
dont les petits boulots parfois aux
blagues parfois pas ont disparu avec la
crise sanitaire depuis un an et qui
aujourd'hui non plus et qui aujourd'hui
n'ont plus ces revenus
il y avait déjà avant une situation qui
était difficile elle s'est juste
énormément aggravée avec même des
problèmes de santé mentale sur lesquels
aujourd'hui des spécialistes sont en
train de nous nous interpeller parce que
quand vous avez ni les moyens pour
pouvoir vous nourrir
les moyens de socialisation qui sont
ceux d'une faculté d'un lieu de travail
d'associations de salle de sports dans
lesquels vous allez que vous retrouvez
seul oui c'est une situation qui est
difficile pourquoi le rsa jeunes parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un moyen d'adresser
un message à la jeunesse en dix ans il y
à ce minimum c'est un minimum c'est le
rsa qu'on vous propose
il est pourquoi à 25 ans qui dit que
cette 25 ans pourquoi pas 18 ans on peut
ouvrir le débat c'est un débat sain et
pourquoi derrière pour dire non pas que
c'est une situation qui est enviable
mais c'est qu'à minima il y à se mettre
là qui permet à près de reposer
l'ensemble des questions que vous posez
moi je pense que si on perd mais en plus
le rsa moi je serais pour qu'il ne soit
pas sollicité mais ils soient accordés à
tous ceux qui peuvent en être
bénéficiaire ya entre 15 et 20 % voire
plus de personnes qui ne le demande pas
aujourd'hui le rsa s'est plaint parce
qu'ils ne savent pas qu'ils y ont droit
alors qu'il rentre dans les critères
je suis pour qu'on les voie là parce
qu'on n'y a droit juste ça et après moi
je suis pour qu'on est pourquoi pas une
expérimentation sur un nombre d'années
donnons-nous cinq ans pour regarder si
c'est utile pas utile et pas
d'expérimentations excusez moi est ce
que ne sait absolument pas la même chose
et vous permettrait quand même de
considérer que entre un système qui est
comme on est de manière universelle tout
le monde et comme on sanctionne quelques
personnes on me met pas ça exactement
sur le même plan là j'en suis pour une
expérimentation oui global
je ne vois pas où l'opposition au
travail ce que ne dit pas madame
elisabeth bande dans ce qu'elle dit
c'est que la proposition du gouvernement
qui a été opposé c'était quoi c'était de
faire un prêt de dix mille euros pour
entrer dans la vie active
donc la solution c'est de s'endetter
c'est ça c'est en fait l'avenir pour la
jeunesse s'est endettée vous quand nous
il ya une solidarité à avoir dans ses
premières années de la vie
alors moi je vais vous dire je vais
donner mon point de vue puisque même si
personne ne me le demande moi je trouve
qu attendait liban est une bonne idée
les ailes et pourquoi
l'endettement est une bonne idée parce
que c'est quand vous avez des études
dont le banquier sait qu'elles vont
déboucher sur un vrai emploi pas
uniquement des études sur sûr
la sociologie comparée pardon ça
concerne que ça comporte
ça concerne tous les jeunes qui ont des
études qui ont des études qui sont
concrètes des études qui sont eux qui
sont au moins les gars sur le marché du
travail est effectivement vous ne
pourrez pas quand vous faites des études
dans les filières sciences humaines
souvent ça sera plus difficile et je
pense que ça permettra de s'interroger
sur ces filières qui sont sans avenir et
qui fabrique à mon avis des gens qui
sont illustrés donc c'est qui en plus
sont prisonnières de deux présupposés
idéologiques en termes d'embauché
logique c'est tout dans votre logique
c'est aux banques et de décider des
études qui sont amenés à logis excusez
moi je pense que c'est un gars logique
c'est tard à pied ainsi malaisie ce qui
est certain c'est que ça on ne peut pas
on ne peut pas le nier c'est qu'il ya
aussi un certain nombre de filières qui
fabrique des futurs chômeurs ça il faut
maintenant est ce que en se saisissant
de la question du prêt est ce qu on ne
prend pas le problème un petit peu à
l'envers
mais si les tirs les études non
pertinentes ou pas non mais la question
n'est pas là la question en italie
puisque si vous avez le préau si vous
n'avez pas c'est en fonction du fait que
vos études débouche sur quelque chose
moi j'ai pas envie que le banques et
décide de savoir si mes études
débouchent sur des prix doit être aussi
tout à fait transparent avec les
étudiants et leur dire quand il s'engage
dans certaines filières qu'elles sont
réellement les débouchés ne pas tricher
sur les télés chiffres comme
actuellement fait d'insertion
professionnelle parce que les
universités sont des spécialistes c'est
incroyable et il faut aussi reconnaître
qu'un certain nombre de filières qui
fabrique en fait après vrai s'est rassis
sur les bancs de la fac
vous allez aller frapper à la porte de
pôle emploi c'est une réalité
après avoir étudié vous allez jeu
au contraire sur les bandes les
internautes alors qu'ils sont pas très
favorables à cette cellule n'est pas
dans les bancs d'une école de commerce
charles existe charge anti sur les bancs
de la fac et ça s'est très bien passé au
chardon bleu au figaro.fr se répandent
dans le rsa que certains vont avoir
envie de travailler
il faut surtout ne pas donner aux jeunes
le goût d'avoir de l'argent de l'état
sans travail et nous dit anne sait
combien on a une chaîne youtube pour un
jeune célibataire ça doit être autour de
500 euros j'imagine c'est sûr qu'on va
fabriquer tout ce qu'on est en train de
dire et puis dan sur youtube qui nous
dit ce n'est pas payé les jeunes à ne
rien faire mais plutôt permettre à cette
jeunesse de survivre dans une situation
extrêmement difficile vous voyez écharpe
ou deux je donnerai lui tellement c'est
bien je vais peut-être olympe dg sur
lefigaro.fr qui nous réconcilient re a
tous en nous disant la solution c'est le
travail voilà merci beaucoup à tous les
deux d'avoir accepté notre invitation
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis et
demain point de vue revient à la même
heure et au même endroit
bonsoir
[Musique]